you know it's interesting you asked me a
question I'm away on the elevator I
didn't want to get into it with you on
the elevator because it was a question
on the elevator you asked me if that was
my only daughter yes my answer is no I
have a 27 year old but were you lied
it's not in lie I just didn't want to
open up the conversation with those
[ __ ] three idiots on I don't know
that's a new thing looking for talking
front of people I won't say no nobody
yeah my dad I don't know all those
pieces tell me about your 27 year old
daughter 27 year old daughter and me
haven't spoken since she's like that but
what I was three I knew what time it was
already I knew that they didn't want me
around her white side of the family hmm
I could see it already and then though I
started packing it and one of those
things she said that really like like I
had to take piss test even though she
would come to the house and take weed
out of the refrigerator I was selling
weed she would come in the house with
the spare key when we were separated and
take weed but she went to the judge and
said you know he smokes pot and they
made me piss on the [ __ ] thing thank
God I knew the probation department and
they wouldn't test me for weed they
would test me for coke and everything
else but they wouldn't test me for weed
so I would continue to smoke weed but
that's the hypocrisy I knew this woman
for a long time yeah but then another
time we went to court and in court she
said that one time I had broken her nose
until this day I'm not cool with her and
one of the reasons why I'm not cool is
yes I was at pretty [ __ ] I did some
bad things when I was growing up but I
copped to all of them I don't like when
people make [ __ ] up like I just went
home in March and some kid I went to my
seventh grade teachers bar he has real
ins a bar now he's like 70 and the
kidding that pulled me outside talk to
you about something because many years
ago you got accused of something the kid
who robbed it came clean and he goes I
always knew you didn't Robin I always
when I was in trouble I was such a piece
of [ __ ] that I would get accused of shot
even do yeah and I'd learned to live
with it because that's the reputation
I had if Bobby Lee's house got a house
got robbed I get the blame Bobby would
blame it had to be Joey and his joy to
be in La Jolla and I would get the blame
that's what I fear about him because he
tells so many stories like sexual
deviance is like in the past that I feel
like anyone could fabricate a story and
be like yeah that would that would be in
line with what he's done in the past so
I always tell him to just be extra the
same way but I'll tell you the truth
yeah yeah I don't like I don't like
what's going on today yeah I don't like
that a woman came out three weeks ago
and said Tom Sizemore molest her when
she's 11 and that's the reason why she
does drugs did you guys see that in - no
no that could happen to anybody anymore
any one of us just that word on a piece
of paper we don't get any more work yeah
yeah we're getting the Mall of America
following Jeremy Piven that's what
that's what it happened yeah that's what
happens before I accuse you of something
I'm gonna be a hundred percent I'm
pretty sure and I'm gonna have a witness
or something you cannot accuse me
without a witness a tape of film I want
to see it I want to see it when the
three-five
before my daughter was born I met a
woman that flappers one night just very
casually in the back she was like that
she did something for flappers and I
didn't die no [ __ ] man come on we
look at rain what am I gonna do with a
girl oh man I got fifty five-year-old
nuts
they look like they're 55 where young
girls suck them I wouldn't get no
satisfaction on I'm walking somebody's
world up I'm just [ __ ] somebody's
world
one time Rogen asked me did you ever
have a girlfriend that committed suicide
no but if anybody suck my dick I'd kill
myself it's disgusting
yeah if she's disgusting we've gone
through comedy hell like it's disgusting
and you know I fingered an Indian
chicken Boise Idaho one time on the
dance floor
I was fingering and she had a yeast
infection happened you know I took my
hand out and it was covered in yoghurt
how the [ __ ] does that happen
[Laughter]
yeah there's it can I just say this
there's a better way to do that and when
next time when a mic one one of my
guests a special guest like this right
he's talking and he's in a [ __ ] you
know in the rhythm of life right and you
pull out one of those things he's the
producer he's gonna do that don't give
me a beat my apologies doing this job I
know but you know men
[Music]